[Musique]
on se doutait bien que la ruine serait
différente cette année un peu partout au
pays l'ontario par exemple notre pas
interdit l'halloween mais a fortement
déconseillé le porte à porte dans les
villes qui sont en zone rouge au québec
est un peu différent la santé publique a
finalement autorisé la collecte de
bonbons à certaines conditions malgré ça
il ya des villes comme rouyn noranda qui
ont décidé d'annuler l'activité
traditionnelle mais on va faire des
choses quand même donc je retrouve la
mairesse de rouyn noranda diane dallaire
bonjour madame dallaire bonjour bon
notre bon matin on ne pas annuler la
louippe quand même vous aviez pris votre
décision début octobre avant que la
santé publique du québec ne se prononcer
ce que vous le regrettez aujourd'hui où
vous non non non pas du tout pas du tout
on vit chez nous un halloween différents
qui va être très festif
et puis les gens participent et la
majorité des commentaires reçus sont
favorables auditions alors on a maintenu
notre décision
donc les petits et les plus grands ont
bien réagi à cette décision là je le
disais pas annuler la louise mais de la
fête de la fête et différemment la wii
c'est pour cela que j'ai mis un peu de
décor pour montrer que c'est quand même
si ce type chez nous il ya eu jugé
dangereux par exemple
alors on se met si notre 31 à rouyn
noranda lors les gens sont invités à
décorer des jeunes on a reçu plus d'une
centaine de photos pour un concours de
photos autant résidentiel questionner
les tissus de décoration de bâtiments
les gens se déguise sont invités à
partager les photos de leurs
déguisements des enfants déguisés pons
une chasse aux bonbons à la maison et
les gens participent en grand nombre à
leur nom des gens sont heureux dont vous
êtes on le peut regretter m'avez-vous
quand même envisager faire marche
arrière madame dallaire entre autres
quand la docteure tam à ottawa dire oui
on peut fêter l'halloween et puis
ensuite le québec a dit ben oui on peut
le faire avec certaines conditions non
on est pauvre revenu sur ma décision la
décision a été prise
une recommandation comme si xavi et
s'étaient joints des partenaires la
sûreté du québec la santé publique vont
le plein de gens autour de la table pour
décider alors on a maintenu une décision
et on s'est dit on voyait les
prud'hommes sont la priorité c'est la
santé de nos citoyens on est oui
l'halloween ces orages mais on est
présentement une des rares régions
encore jeune et puis on veut y demeurer
alors on a mis on a décidé de maintenir
la décision
non justement vous dites on est en zone
jaune ça veut dire que les bars sont
ouverts les restrictions sont pas les
mêmes qu'en zone rouge est ce que vous
craignez des adultes fasse la fête même
si le docteur arruda des conseillers à
ce jour je vous dirais puis je félicite
vraiment les citoyens non seulement de
ronaldo mais de la région les gens sont
très très respectueux des mesures qui
sont en place alors j'ai confiance bien
sûr la sûreté du québec est présente
pour faire de la sensibilisation au
sommet vraiment je fais confiance aux
gens parce que ce jour je vous dis que
ça se passe quand même très bien chez
nous bon alors vous le disiez beaucoup
d'activités qui sont organisés beaucoup
de décoration c'est dans la ville
aujourd'hui votre maison non non mais
d'aller commerces et bureaux et on a dit
comme un centre ville
offert gratuitement des dix citrouille
aux citoyens pour décorer la maison sur
leur nom c'est vraiment festif tout de
même et puis les enfants ont pu se
déguiser à l'école ou si il ya eu quand
même les gens les enfants ont pu en
profiter
et puis le bain jouets qu'il y avait du
souper avec les engins des familles qui
déguisent et peut-être des choses qu'on
se faisait alors les gens se sont
réinventés alors c'est vraiment on se
réinvente depuis le début de la pandémie
alors pour louis toulouze wings et la
chine
merci beaucoup madame dallaire au revoir
c'est un peu différent à rimouski les
petits monstres les princesses les super
héros vont pouvoir passer d'une porte à
l'autre dans les rues de la ville avec
la bulle familiale bien sûr parce qu'au
québec je vous le rappelle qu'avec 19
oblige
il ya des consignes très strictes en
termes de santé publique pour en parler
de tissot virtuel à rimouski avec le
maire marc parent bonjour monsieur
parent bonjour alors vous avez décidez
vous de votre côté contrairement aux
anneaux randa d'autoriser cette
cueillette de bonbons c'est la santé
publique qui vous a motivé j'imagine à
cette décision assure t on une chute de
santé publique
oui on autorise mais quand même on
recommande cet avis de modifier les
habitudes puis à ondjiva d'accord
peut-être sur steam est limité car
dévoilé lors de la bulle
et il ya d'autres alternatives et je
suis très très fier de la proche qu'on a
pris entre autres choses avait-il du
biotech y annoncer que ce téléphone
avait démissionné quatre bibliothèques
trois bibliothèques de quartier où les
gens sont invités aujourd'hui à 100 dans
l'est du québec
la remettre des livres des bonbons puis
on va également leur donner leur faire
prendre conscience qu'il est possible
d'aller sur le site web de la ville de
new skies qui s'appelle quoi vivre husky
point ca et le personnel des
bibliothèques avec énormément de plaisir
ça a l'air ont enregistré des contes
d'halloween
mais les contours maintenant disponible
depuis ce matin jusqu'au 6 novembre deux
comptes
et puis j'avais de belles opportunités
base pour les familles d'écouté à la
maison c'est contre j'ai écouté ce matin
très tôt sont vraiment très très épuré
ce type a maintenant une opportunité
depuis la loi de façon un petit peu
différente en respectant des règles
parce que voyez-vous sur le territoire
d'avis de nouveaux skins où on a
vraiment vu comment thèse que la
situation de la commune peut déraper
traître est gratuit vous avez connu un
épisode difficile de transmission de la
coved avez-vous des cris quand même qu'à
une certaine tranche d'âge peut-être
qu'ils fassent la fête est ce qu'on va
davantage surveillés abello vous suivez
un excellent point soldats c'est
extrêmement important territoire david
bouskila partout au québec
ce n'est pas d'avoir des party
d'halloween avec les adultes
on vit des moments difficiles comme je
mentionnais le tanto allait d'ailleurs
d'une période
nous on a vraiment vu une augmentation
de substantielle des coffres
heureusement ça descendu dans les
derniers jours mais il faudra être
extrêmement plus tard il faut mais bien
une ruelle de distanciation physique et
donne une nouvelle façon de vivre à
louis ii cette année je suis d'ailleurs
moi pendant qu'on le croyait un concours
de photographie c'est la famille de
marine et oued et kevin sont sortis ce
matin ils ont pu encourager au foie pour
vivre le but ce matin ce sera donc en
bulle familiale et des allemands dans le
quartier peut-être un peu moins de
maisons qu'à l'habitude le port du
masque mais là on va pouvoir être
créatifs pour le port du masque
évidemment et puis tout ça dans le froid
je mange il faut bien s'habiller ça doit
être très chaud chez vous aujourd'hui
non ben sassi pendant tout ce qui rend
ce matin mais je pense qu de terre à 2
degrés mais elle est consécutive à
servier oui tout à fait mais il fait
beau et pas de pluie merci beaucoup
merci aussi au revoir